скажи чесно Як ти скаржитися мене
древлять якісь екстремальні ситуації В
мене немає
якогось такого відчуття можливо саме
збереження я
уявляю собі таку бульбашку довкола
будинку
і сюди точно нічого не прилетить
Наступного разу Спробуй ще так обери
собі невеличкий заспокійливий амулет
щось щоб лізе в долоню це може бути
якийсь особливий камінчик ґудзик чи
перстень те що викликає приємні спогади
та відчуття добре щоб ця річ була завжди
під рукою Коли відчуєш негатив візьми в
долоні амулет і сконцентруйся на
відчуттях які він викликає опиши по
думки форму колір вагу
це має тебе стабілізувати додай цю
техніку в свою аптечку самодопомоги
більше тут